welcome back a couple of weeks ago we
talked about velveeta and how they
released a new martini i think we were
all a little taken aback by that but no
need to worry because the wonder woman
of cheese diana breyer is here to show
us a great way to incorporate cheese
into your martini so your guests will
come back welcome back
thanks great to have you we missed you
so much it's so good to have you back
and
martinis and cheese we've done wine and
cheese many times wine and cheese beer
and cheese a lot of people think about
like classic cheese pairings sometimes
even going over to whiskey and cheese
yeah but not a lot of people actually
think about the prospect of pairing
cocktails with your cheese and it's
really just about extrapolating flavor
profiles that will be complementary so
we decided to answer the call of the
velveeta martini and make some martinis
that are really going to not really be
offensive to your guests and that's what
i'm excited about you always listen to
people and what their tastes are and you
you can put together things on that and
you know that i like spice i do and i
like sweet and you created two drinks
for that talk to us about it i did so
one of the first things we did we
actually just started off with a
standard vodka so this is something that
you can just get anywhere okay you know
at valley cheese and wine we don't sell
hard alcohol just wine but we just
thought it would be so fun to play
around so we have this vodka here we
actually infused just hot water and
mike's hot honey okay to make a spicy
simple syrup oh
and then we infuse that simple syrup
with rosemary and we garnish with a
piece of big john's cajun cheddar from
beehive in utah and then wrapped it with
some calabrese some spicy salami put a
little sprig of rosemary in there go
ahead and taste it okay so do i drink it
do i bite you know grab a piece of the
cheddar that's right here this one what
i want you to do is like chew that
cheddar up just a little bit a few bites
of cheddar and while it's like really
saturating your palate go ahead and
introduce that martini and you'll notice
the flavors are perfectly complementary
but they also allow a lot of punchiness
and a lot of like a surprising cocktail
oh my god it's very surprising
i don't know how you do that how do you
figure out
wow i have a mental rolodex of cheese so
really and like the rosemary in there it
just it really helps yeah it produces
this sort of like punchy herbaceous
undertone that really allows the cajun
spices to come forward and that's these
chilies that are infused into the honey
and the simple syrup to really sing on
the palate this
is fantastic okay let's go sweet i don't
know how we're going to top that that
was really good okay so this one is
really interesting because we decided to
use again vodka and we did a little bit
of apple schnapps and a little bit of
butter like better shots or butterscotch
schnapps
to create sort of a caramel apple
sensation on the palate but then we
actually use an aged sheep milk gouda
because sheep milk goudas tend to have
nice like butterscotchy caramel
undertones so it plays together really
beautifully so go ahead and take another
piece of take a piece of the gouda this
is the gouda same thing you're going to
want to like chew it a few times and
allow those butterscotch tones to really
like lay around on the palette and then
introduce that martini the nice thing
about these drinks is that they are so
fun so different so unique they're
perfect and applicable for summer time
but these flavor profiles will also take
you wonderfully into fall this tastes
like fall in a glass it does doesn't it
this is delicious it's a caramel apple
but why does the cheese make it taste
even better it's because of those
butterscotch and caramel undertones that
are present in this specific type of
gouda that allow for those like those
tones in the martini to really sing and
bring out those caramel for you i'm
going to be here all day eating cheese
and drinking martinis i don't know about
you okay diana tell everyone where they
can find you to experience this goodness
so i am valley cheese and wine so i'm on
1570 west horizon ridge parkway we're in
henderson in the mcdonald ranch area
valley cheese and wine.com really easy
way to find us all the information's on
our website we're pretty active on
social media
the best thank you so much